so
good afternoon welcome to the
continuation
of the community of conference on house
okay
mr kane we have two items that i would
like to take up i understand
i mean we left the sununu center and i
also
understand that senator rosenwald has an
amendment for us
on section 39.
maybe we could start with her amendment
sure
i don't know if anyone has it yet
i don't think so section 39 um
it's 37 to 40 and it starts on page
20 if you want to look in your side by
sides
yes thank you actually this amendment
refers
specifically to language in the middle
of page
24.
and please look to page 24. we're
looking if you're at home we're looking
at amendment
2021-2012 s
please senator thank you madam chair
this
amendment removes uh the mandatory
ultrasounds that are
uh in the language of house bill 2
required
for any before any abortion
can be performed in new hampshire and
i bring this before the conference
committee because
mandatory ultrasounds before all
abortions
defies medical standards which the
legislature is not qualified to do
they are unnecessary and they will
contribute
to higher medical spending and likely
increased health care premiums
the american college of obstetrics and
gynecologists
have stated that routine ultrasounds are
not considered medically necessary
as a component of first trimester
abortions
and to quote from their guidance for
patients with regular menstrual cycles
a certain last menstrual period within
the prior
56 days and no sign
symptoms or risk factors for ectopic
pregnancy
a clinical examination or ultrasound
examination
is not necessary before medication
abortion and madam chair i believe that
forcing
patients to have an ultrasound before
even a first trimester abortion is
shaming
and it's an unnecessary barrier to care
it will most impact our low-income
residents who already face
burdens this will require them to travel
and to pay for the additional cost of
the procedure
and ultrasound can be quite expensive
and i believe we should be giving
doctors the flexibility to use their
expertise
and their judgment that qualifies them
for a license to practice
medicine in new hampshire rather than
substituting
our own unqualified medical judgment
resulting in unnecessary expensive
services
i see this as an insurance mandate as
well
and i think it will likely contribute to
increasing cost of private health
insurance
thank you thank you senator questions or
discussion that represent wyler
so i'm looking on thank you madam chair
uh senator you have your mind all right
let me just say this we have some
construction equipment working outside
we've asked them to try to either not
work or
take a break long lunch something but in
case
you're going to speak pull your mic as
close as you can so everybody
in the back of the room can hear because
i think it's more back there and it
impacts their ability
to hear thank you representative wyler
thank you for letting me interfe
interrupt thank you madam chair thank
you senator so the result of this
amendment before us 2012 s
is the elimination of most of the
language in the
in the paragraph that we're looking at
on page 24.
correct representative weiler it keeps
the first
sentence and strikes the rest of that
paragraph
in i thank you i just wanted to make
sure what the effect was
thank you if i am correct senator could
i ask
this was a senate added section
that the house did not have is that
correct
correct okay representative edwards do
you have a
question uh thank you madam chair i do
have a question
uh as as i understand the history
of uh requiring ultrasounds
before an abortion it's been primarily
about
providing the mother an opportunity to
really provide informed consent that the
ultrasound images
uh can be useful but for that
mother to uh connect to the baby that's
inside of her
so that she's better able to make a
decision about whether or not she wants
to go forward with the procedure
that that's my understanding of the
history could you could you speak to
that
well it's not the medical standard
non-medical people
but i think the result of
that is to imply that women are not
capable
of making decisions about their own
families bodies economic security and
future
without intervention that's not
considered medically
necessary
follow-up uh yes i just want to point
out that i've not
implied that women are not capable of
making these medical decisions i ask you
a question about the history and i just
want to be
clear that i i think women are fully
capable
okay we have a we have amendment
2021-2012 s
we've discussed it we do not at the
moment have a motion
i'd like to move it senator rosenwald
moves her amendment 2021-2012 s
seeing no second we will not be
proceeding with this amendment
thank you for your work senator
rosenwald i'm so happy
comes this is like many of my
suggestions for the budget they just
don't go anywhere
especially the one that gets me a new
car or something
we had a fairly exhaustive but not
totally exhaustive
it's a new new center discussion
we had a couple of ideas
for an amendment we may have had two
amendments
uh one of them incorporated something
that represented walner
thought she wanted to go ahead with
which i said i would put in my name
which was fine
she has decided not to go ahead with
that amendment
so do we have an amendment on the sununu
center that we can bring forward at this
time
i'm not yet okay
so not yet do we have an amendment
on that wonderful dedicated fund that we
were allowed to put a dollar in
and it could grow no more than a maximum
of a dollar
yes 1995 h has is an amendment we'll
hand out now
and that has to do with the cobin 19
micro
enterprise relief fund as well as the
save our granite stages fund
at this time senator gary daniels is
going to
join us at the table senator gary
daniels
is the chairman of senate finance
he's done a wonderful job getting us
where we are today
he's been with us every day he has been
an alternate
and he is now joining us at the table
and gary we thank you for all the work
you and your team did and
i think mr hoffman because there are a
couple of changes in here
can walk us through this section after
he's passed out the amendments
so if you're at home we are looking at
and this replaces section 452
can you hear me okay yes it's on page
349 if you're looking at the big
books yes mr hoffman we can
no yes so for the micro enterprise
relief fund
um 348. on the top of 348 there's no
change to section 451.
is changed by removing the one dollar
amount
then on the next row you'll read public
health emergency
shall be deposited into the fund that's
been changed to maybe
deposited into the fund
and then the row below it that says
provided that
at no time shall the balance of the fund
exceed a dollar that is removed
and in roman numeral two you'll see up
then if we go all the way to roman
numeral four
you'll see a reference up to a dollar
that is removed
there's no change to 453
on the bottom of 350 there's no change
to 454
or 455 or 456.
section 457 which starts on the bottom
of 352
toward the bottom third row up that one
dollar amount is removed
i'm sorry i'm popping back and forth
between the side by side and the
amendment here
and then there's another shell that's
changed to
may be deposited in the fund the reason
for that is
the way that's worded uh notwithstanding
any other provision of law
if it were shell that could be taken
that all of the money would go into that
font
so this uh makes
there's another action required there's
no money in the budget so there would
have to be a fiscal and gnc
accept and expend so may works
um better in this case than just the one
dollar limitation
thank you questions comments sandra
bradley
i would love a motion i move uh
amendment 1995
ought to pass second represent
umber seconds represent bradley moves
out to pass
on two zero two one one nine nine five h
on section 457 and the amendment i still
what play what line number are you um
i'm on
1985 yeah i think those shells
consistent so the first one on line 15
is just the standard language shall be
appropriated for 22. so what that does
is
there's no money in here that's
appropriated but it just makes sure that
it's specifically related to 22 and that
gives direction on what that fund will
be used for
the second shell on 19 is the standard
shelby non-lapsing
just to give the treasurer a in
department administrative services clear
direction that anything that does go
into that fund
based on that further action that mike
hoffman talked about um would be
uh non-lapsing excuse me follow-up
i thought i heard you in referring to
that saying that the shell had been
changed to me
and i thought you were just distinctly
referring to 457.
yeah let me just move to mike i don't
know if he was talking about the um
21 line 21 yes on row 21
that used to read shall and that was
changed to me
maybe deposited okay that was the one
all right thank you
appreciate it okay we have a
motion on the floor and a second
if house members are in a favor would
you please raise your hand
senator morris the senate we unanimously
accept this and mike that includes
all sections related to that
okay okay okay
if you look at your compare report page
we have section 439
senate pass on page 332
the house the senate will accede to the
house on that section
beyond that we have sections 440 to 442.
and the senate will accede to the house
mike do we know how long it's going to
be before we get this a new new center
amendment
i would say at least 15 minutes there is
one item though i could bring you to
if you would like based on an action in
another community conference today
uh yes sure let's do that and
that will bring you on the uh shaded out
side-by-side data
dated 615 on page 13 at the top
senate pass section uh 387 to 388
actually i'm sorry is that the wrong one
mickey it's the wrong one
mickey will tell you the actual place to
go
if you go to page 14 on the uh index
it'd be the second to the last row at
the bottom it's a new section
uh relative to the gun line um
reductions made
in a reference to senate bill 141 so
this would be
amendment 1944 h that's been previously
adopted by this committee
i think we are all looking at that so
just so you know representative umberger
did yeoman's work on this amendment got
all the details worked out
the house had passed the bill and
representative umberger was not in favor
of passage of the bill but she still
rolled up her sleeves said hey we wanted
it we passed it i'm going to do the work
dug in got all the positions figured out
how much money should have been budgeted
for the counties because it downshifted
money
to the county downshift to work to the
counties without giving them the money
to do it
went through everything we passed it
senator guyda called this morning and
said he had a community of conference
that was on the gun line
he would like to put this amendment on
it they put it on their amendment in the
gun line
so we need to agree to reconsider
does is a house an agreement for
reconsideration
and the sentencing agreement uh
representative umberger i think you
would like to speak to perhaps
withdrawing your
amendment for uh yes i'd like to
withdraw
amendment uh 19th or
the house is unanimously in favor of
that given the recent actions
is the senate okay that is withdrawn and
will no longer be in
hb2 thank you mike for reminding me of
that
karen told me you told me it slipped my
mind
so the sununu center amendment i would
probably request a
15 to 20 minute break i know that's not
ideal
but just to make sure we have the proper
amendment and the proper copies
that would be lovely we it's 1 35
can we post that we are in a break for
20 minutes please
yes we will do that okay thank
come to any you on dental benefits why
not
okay does everybody have a copy
this deals with the sununu center
representative edwards would you like to
mr cain i'm going to have you run
through us i've already had some
questions i couldn't answer we're
probably going to have
questions so if we can go through the
amendment it would be appreciated
sure um 2024h
is an amendment to section 330 relative
to the suny new center and the committee
established to develop a plan for
closure and replacement of the sununu
youth services center
uh the there will be three members of
the house of representatives each of
whom shall be from a standing committee
having jurisdiction over
juvenile justice two members of the
senate appointed by the president of the
senate
in addition legislative members of the
committee shall seek input
expert advice from department of health
and human services child advocate
disability rights center national
alliance on mental illness new futures
and any other group or
organization the committee deems
necessary legislative members of the
community shall receive mileage at the
legislative rate
the committee shall develop a plan for
the closure and replacement
or repurposing that was one change it
was put in of the sununu services center
including cost estimates for the
construction and operation of a new
facility
the committee's plan shall consider
that's another change the following
it may be operated by the department of
health and human services
shall be designed to meet the unique
needs of up to 18 youth at a time
shall accommodate requirements to
separate youth by gender treatment needs
court order safety and security
facilities shall include three separate
residential spaces each including
capacity
for up to six you shall have the
capacity to provide services to meet the
medical physical and behavioral health
needs of all potentially eligible youth
turning over to page two
uh shall have space for up to 18 beds
including space for flexibility to meet
the needs of all gender safety and
security
crisis stabilization and admission and
discharges
shall have adequate space to meet the
educational needs of all youth
adequate space for indoor and outdoor
recreation the capacity to meet the
nutritional needs of all youth
and the necessary elements to be
architecturally secure and equipped with
video surveillance
the opening of the replacement facility
shall be no later than may 1st 2023
the committee shall prepare
sorry march 1st what did i say may i'm
sorry yeah
okay it is march 1st 2023 on line 9
of the amendment sorry the committee
shall prepare legislation relative to
the implementation of plan to belton
paragraph four
foot submission for the 2022 legislative
session
and then uh subparagraph five uh six
members of the study committee shall
elect a chairperson from among the
members
first meeting shall be held 30 days of
the effective date of this section
and then the final sections 16 through
on line 16 through 18. committee shall
issue their filing report to the speaker
of the house of representatives the
senate president senate clerk the house
clerk the governor in the state library
on or before november 1st 2021 and
submit the plan to the joint fiscal
committee for
approval thank you mr kane
discussion representative weiler
i think it's a mistake on a committee
that's going to talk about
a building and
and funding to just have people from
jurisdiction over juvenile justice
why not have public works and finance
people on this as well
because the decisions that will be
affecting this have much to do with the
areas of expertise
on those committees not just juvenile
justice thank you
and i guess that's a provision in the
senate side does the senate want to
share
their thoughts
well they have they're mulling that over
i have i have a thought i thought that
uh roman numeral 2
where it says in addition the
legislative members of the committee
shall seek input and expert advice
from but not limited to
and so to me you don't need someone from
public works there
until you decide to build a new building
for example so i think that
to me anyhow that would cover the
representative weiler made but that's
i guess it does say any other group or
organization the committee deems
necessary so
it opens the door for them to
contact anybody represent weiler
representative edwards uh to uh
to representative weiler's point i i i
agree with him
and and given that yesterday we talked
about how it would be great to give this
community flexibility
i i would i would recommend starting on
line six
right after the comma where the word
each starts each of whom
delete through the next all the way to
the next comma
so it would read three members of the
house of represented
appointed by the speaker of the house
and the speaker and his
judgment can pick which three
representatives would be best on this
committee
i think one of the concerns which
represent walnut
mentioned to me before we sat back down
was that this committee will have a lot
to do with money as well but nobody is
specifically invited to sit on this
committee
from finance and i think we've seen
a couple of other bills this year that
criminal justice bill that we just
rescinded the amendment that
representation berger had to work on to
resolve all the issues after it passed
that did have financial implications
i think we'd be good with you
representative edward's suggestion if
that's the will of the house that's
okay let's hold that thought while we
continue to work on this what else do we
have
ladies and gentlemen i know we've just
seen this for the first time but it does
use much of the language
that has been in our compare bill
includes what we talked about yesterday
so it's not
brand new we've just seen it for the
first time representative edwards
uh thank you madam chair and this is
just to make sure that we're all clear
on the legislative intent
uh on the second page line
one it says it shall have space for up
to 18
beds including space for flexibility
i i think when we went from 5 to 18
that implied that we want to have
flexibility
and so i would hate the committee to
think that
they need 18 beds plus more space for
more flexibility i i just say that
within the 18 they're building
the flexibility and i'm not proposing we
change anything
i'm just trying to make sure that our
legislative intent is clear
okay
represent weiler uh we have velax that's
providing an excellent job and remote
uh learning and i hope we take that into
account so we don't think we have to
have
uh a dozen teachers for each grade and
subject
that they can just sign up for a vlax
course if there's one person taking
sixth grade english we don't need to
have a teacher specifically for that we
can have an online course
i think i'm glad that we have that
capability
i believe you heard um represent
edward's
point on page one line six and line
that we would have three members of the
house of representatives
each of whom shall be from a standing
committee appointed by the speaker of
the house
we all sit on standing committee so i
think that will be okay
do we have to wait for more paperwork
don't worry is that something you could
magically make happen for us
we will magically make it happen
excellent
senator bradley are you ready for a
motion madam chair i am senator
i haven't i have a question represented
by berger has a question i'm sorry
um representative edwards
recommended that we take out
from each of whom shall be from a
standing committee having jurisdiction
over juvenile justice and what i thought
i heard you say
i left in each of whom shall be from a
standing committee
which would include finance yep okay
i just want because we are a standing
committee we're
we're the policy committee that deals
with money but we are a standing policy
committee
okay and the the other question i have
is it is the way this r
is written they don't have to have 18
beds
no that's why it says up to they're
gonna have some other numbers what
is that am i interpreting that correctly
line
24 on page 1 begins this it says
it shall be designed to meet the unique
needs
of up to 18 youth
and then it goes through and says
has the same three residential pods that
representative edwards spoke about
yesterday
and obviously when we have three
residential pods
and we have five beds you're going to
have 1.6 beds in each of the three pods
if you split it evenly
so if you have three pods you really
want to have it
a multiple of three so shall include
three separate residential pods
each including capacity for up to
six youth so now you could actually have
one bed in one pod and four beds and
another one if you had more of this kind
of child the way that's
written
maybe we're ready for a motion now
senator bradley uh i'll move
that we approve the amendment with your
changes that you referred to as
lba magic
is there a second to that represent
wyler's seconds
if the house is in favor will you please
raise your hand
senate
okay mr kane we do
have a great deal of open
space related to the sununu center
starting on page 11. have we now
dealt with every one of those
sections we would just need
the intent of the committee to be stated
if the house will accede to the senate's
position
after that amendment that was just
adopted okay then the house does succeed
to the senate position
with the adoption of amendment
2021-2024-h
has changed with lba magic yes
is amended with lba magic
and the top of page 12 that includes all
of those as well correct mr kane
that's correct straight through on the
i think senator morse would like to
address
senate pass sections 427
and 429 the house did speak
about those sections yesterday
and i recognize the senate senator moore
senator bradley
let me just start out by saying that um
having
you know worked for a long time on
medicaid expansion i
i see the dental benefit in much the
same way as something that would
improve not only oral health but
physical health
the senate and it was in my committee
the health and human services committee
took
um a lot of testimony
physicians dentists etc that talked of
the
correlation between good oral health and
good overall
physical health it's unfortunate that
the cost savings that we would enjoy
from better physical health of never to
the best of my knowledge ever been
delineated in a cost-benefit analysis
but every medical professional
has testified to that effect so
the senate um has supported the dental
benefit
in the previous session in this session
the costs uh general fund costs are
about
six to seven million dollars it's
estimated
over the course of a of a year the way
that the
the fact that it goes into
implementation in the last quarter of
the
second year of the budget
limits the cost to the 1.6 ish million
dollars that's
so i guess at this point i'd be happy to
answer any questions i think we would
hope that the
um house conferees would see their way
to
supporting this i think it makes
a lot of sense from a public health
perspective
it certainly the testimony that we
received would help
get people that needed dental care
back into the workforce if they had
dental care which would be
helpful obviously to our economy if the
house
wanted to have us adopt a provision
that was similar to medicaid expansion
where
we tied continued funding to the
federal funding that would be available
in the matches
i think part of the match and people
from hhs can answer this would be at a
50 50 rate and part of it would be at a
medicaid expansion rate is that correct
a 90 10 match
so it would bring a significant amount
of money
federal resources into the state of new
hampshire
so i i think it's a very worthy program
the senate has
so happy to answer any questions madam
chair
thank you senator bradley i think this
is kind of like house bill
254 which we have retained in house
finance
and division three on some of the
situation with sununu center the senate
did pass their bill but they immediately
put it on the table
it has not come to the house for public
hearing we do
have some figures that say it could cost
up to 11 million dollars a year
in general funds we haven't looked at
that and so
we're hoping that the senate will send
their bill
over when they get them so that we can
have those
public hearings but right now we do not
have 11 million dollars extra to commit
on the budget so we appreciate the work
you did we're looking forward to working
with you
in the future on this
mr kane i think we still have a couple
of issues we were
waiting for our speaker who had was
detained oh he's here
mr kane it's my understanding that we do
have an amendment
um on language that was
the equivalent of house bill 417 the
mr shea says yes we do if we could
thank you mike
sorry they are passing out amendment
2021-2017-s
which is being offered by senator morris
senator bradley
represent packard and myself
i think they've passed it out
mike do you want to walk us through it
please
sure amendment 2017
men's rsa 445 subparagraphs 1 and 2.
one of the changes you'll see beginning
on page 8 through page 11
relative to the governor shall notify
the speaker of the house of
representatives and the senate president
of the impending issuance
of emergency orders under this section
and provide a description of such
orders next change down on line 17 the
duration of the state of emergency
that's less than 30 days it was amended
from 21 to 30.
on line 18 similar amendment state of
emergency shall terminate automatically
instead of 21
30 days after its declaration on
page sorry same page
line 24 there's an amendment to
subparagraph
2c which states that the legislature may
terminate a state of emergency
or an emergency order issued there under
by a majority vote of both the senate
and the house of representatives
the majority of this vote shall consist
of a majority of members present
and voting in each chamber acting
separately
the governor's power to renew a
declaration of a state of emergency
shall terminate upon a majority vote of
both chambers
under this sub-paragraph also
on page 2 on line 4 is amending 4 485 by
adding
new subparagraph after subparagraph 3
the following
uh subparagraph from a numeral 4 members
of the legislature shall be exempt
from any emergency orders that would
infringe on their ability to travel
and conduct their business as
representatives of the people
sub-paragraph five beginning on line
eight no federal
private or other non-state gift grant or
loan for purposes of emergency powers of
the state which exceeds a hundred
thousand dollars shall be accepted until
such action shall be approved by the
fiscal committee of the general court
under this section the governor shall
submit an item to the chairperson of the
fiscal committee
for consideration if the fiscal
committee of the general court does not
accept or reject the item within five
business days
the governor may accept and expend the
funds without further action
by the fiscal committee also on
beginning on
line 15 under circumstances requiring
emergency action for immediate health
safety and welfare of the citizens the
governor has the sole authority to
accept and expend
funds they're under within 24 hours of
the governor's
acceptance and expenditure of the funds
the governor shall notify the senate
president speaker of the house and chair
of the fiscal committee
of the acceptance and expenditure of
such funds
and on line 20 an amendment to 21p
by adding a new section 21p 43a
that the governor shall provide a list
of all expenditures pursuant to the
subdivision
under state of emergency to the
executive council for
informational purposes only within 30
days of the expenditure
in order to ensure transparency in
sections one through three will take
senator bradley thank you very much i
think one of the
key sticking points in all of the
discussion about this
is whether the legislature
has the authority to override or stop an
emergency order or
parts of an emergency order or whether
the legislature has to affirmatively
renew an emergency order that
has been the key sticking point if it's
the legislature overriding
the governor that's an affirmative
action
in much the same way constitutionally
that we would pass a law by majority
vote
to put a piece of legislation on the
governor's desk that's an affirmative
action
by both bodies the house and the senate
obviously if the governor disagrees he
or she vetoes it and by a two-thirds
majority
we as the house and senate have the
ability to override
so flipping
the script so to speak to say
that the legislature has to
affirmatively
agree to continue
an emergency order is
way outside the traditional and i think
constitutional
checks and balances that
we have in new hampshire upon a
governor's authority would allow either
the senate
or the house to decline to
move forward with an emergency order or
potentially at the discretion of the
senate president or the speaker
declined to even meet and consider it
and so
the emergency order would then cease to
exist
by that action that i think is
somewhat unprecedented in how
we traditionally do business the one
thing that i would add
that if you look at the amendment
uh 2021 constitutionally
you know an action of the governor in
terms of legislation it takes two-thirds
this is a majority vote of both the
senate
and the house so a simple majority in
this case
would override either the entire
emergency order or
specific emergency orders that was one
of the key distinctions that the senate
made
when we passed 417 is that
current law allows override provision of
an entire order but not specific orders
so
by doing that i think it's by doing this
if we do this
um and my understanding is the governor
is supportive of this
and it's been scrutinized extensively by
the governor's office this
provides i think a further check and
balance on emergency orders by being
able
to block an emergency order by a simple
majority vote where
any other action to block a governor's
veto or to override a governor's veto is
two-thirds
so that's why i think this is a good
amendment a good
way forward and i would hope that we can
support it
thank you senator bradley i would like
then speaker shertliff arbitrarily
sent the legislature home and locked us
out
whether we wanted to come work or not we
were totally
all of us locked out of the state house
blocked out the lobby
the governor was here by himself we were
not allowed to even come up here
people have said to me well he wasn't
talking the legislature
they forget that the speaker at that
time
blocked us out i don't think we'd ever
faced something exactly like this
although certainly
president eisenhower had a sort of
pandemic on his side which had the same
amount of death as we had with
the coronavirus this allows the
legislature
no matter who is speaker to continue to
work and to continue to be part of the
process
which is something i think is was needed
then
and is needed now and i'm glad to see
that the legislature and the governor
will
go forward as both bodies
executive and legislative need to be
working for the people
at all times representative omburger you
did have your hand up
uh thank you madam chairman
uh looking at lines um
17 or 27 28 and 29.
h1 yes um
quorum
i'm not qualified to answer that
question so i'm kind of hoping that
i have i have no problem with it i just
but i guess mr speaker i would ask you
that
we have house rules that if a quorum of
house members
aren't present that we have to pass
no just press the red button it'll be
okay yeah there's there's two phases to
that i mean if
if we drop below well whatever the
number is 260 264 or whatever you know
depending on how many members we have at
that time
then you have to pass by two-thirds vote
if we drop below let's say 200
uh in one then we don't have a quorum
where we have to stop
and i guess the question that
representative umberger is bringing
forward to us is does this override that
i'm not qualified to answer that
question
yeah hold on mentally i
i certainly don't want to uh make a
determination uh unless you know
somebody
gives us a legal explanation but i would
assume that our rules would still
be in play even with this that's what i
would drop
you know that we need at least well 201
if we had you know all 400 members that
we
would have to have at least a minimum of
201 there
nothing in this bill suspends house
rules
so karen i think the answer may be house
rules are not suspended
and as the speaker said we do have a
house rule on that
except this says a majority vote
shall consist of a majority of the
members present and voting
and so you know and as we just said if
you
fall below a certain number you need two
thirds
and so this in fact overrides that
this overrides defined below two-thirds
yes
wait a minute miss represent turcotte
where i think they've stepped out to see
if
the attorney is available is that true
can we ask for the governor's office to
uh mr elms the senator asked very
politely
if the governor's office would like to
comment on this
and you're not obliged to say yes and
i'm looking at your face
but if you wanted to we would be happy
to have you comment do we have a
microphone back there now
if we could wait for james scully
governor's legal counsel to arrive we'd
appreciate that
on is on his way matt then i have a
couple of other members who have
comments i'm gonna let them go ahead
while we
hold this representative turcotte your
hand was up first followed by represent
wyler
thank you madam chair um i
i have to believe the intent of this
would be that it contemplates a state of
emergency where
maybe every single member might not be
able to get there whether that number be
ten percent down twenty percent fifty
percent down
and i think the wording to me says
exactly that
whoever is there it's a majority of
those present
not so much uh requiring a quorum that
would be
personally that's how i would read it
represent weiler
i can envision dire emergencies that
would affect the majority of the state
either disabling our vehicles so we
couldn't travel or our roads or our
electricity
or even an attack like say a meteorite
hit that wiped out
a fraction of the state there are dire
things that could happen and those that
must have remained and survive
would be expected to do something so
depending on how dire the emergency was
we should be able to do something
thank you senator morris
yeah our attorney is on his way over but
he said that the constitution requires a
quorum
so it would not be just the people that
show up
okay the constitution requires a quorum
a bill may not overturn the constitution
i think representative berger we may
have
reached an answer however we have a
couple of attorneys
on their way over
[Music]
so that's going to probably lead us to a
five-minute
break if they're on their way i hesitate
to take a longer break so that they
don't sit around
so ladies and gentlemen we're going to
take a wee tiny
five minute break and make sure we're
constitutionally correct
all right we had a question on the floor
that is probably going to be a
constitutional question however
we asked the governor's office if they
would like to speak and we were
kindly provided with the governor's
attorney and
thank you for coming i think you have a
microphone back there
we're questioning the language and the
question was
do we have to have a quorum and we
believe that the constitution does say
that the house
and senate must have a quorum in order
to do business and welcome and thank you
for coming over to help us
senate attorney sorry
it's been a long three days
doesn't sound like it doesn't sound like
how's that well perfect um yes the
quorum is required
either the senator or the house to
conduct any business so
um in the constitution correct in the
constitution
and it can't be changed by statute
obviously
thank you and i think the speaker our
speaker has
the language from the constitution he
can read for us so we all know what
we're dealing with here
thank you madam chair uh article 20
quorum what constitutes
and i'll just read it a majority of the
members of the house of representatives
shall be a quorum for doing business
but less than two-thirds of the
representatives elected shall be present
the absence of two-thirds of those
numbers shall be necessary to render
their acts and proceeding
uh valid um so it's what we anticipated
that
if we have all 400 members then once we
drop below 201
we'd have to cease business so this this
language here does not change or trump
the constitution
and we thank representative umberger for
helping us get
a little better in tune with the
constitution of new hampshire
any other comments on this amendment and
again we're looking at amendment
2021-2017-s
cnn are we ready for a motion i'll move
the amendment
senator bradley moves the amendment
representative packard's seconds
if the house is in favor would you
please raise your hand
the senate we have adopted this
senator bradley and i have been working
on this broadband project and it doesn't
matter how much we work
we always have one more little wiggle
senator bradley i think we have now a
committee of conference
that has agreed to something that needs
to go
into the amendment on the broadband that
this committee adopted am i correct
uh yes madam chair you are and i
apologize for having forgotten
um the senate amended house bill 77
which you concurred with to back
date the broadband eligibility criteria
to
january 1st of this year
you concurred with that i apologize i
forgot
about that provision i was reminded of
it by a colleague in the senate
and so if you go to um
house bill 77 it is
section two broadband matching grand
initiative
it does do the back dating it's
contingency language i think that
um the legislative budget assistance
and ols can as we're
saying with some frequency now work
their magic to make sure that that
provision
is included in the broadband
language and so i would move that
both the senate and house have already
voted for this provision
again i apologize for having dropped it
okay i would
second the motion by senator bradley to
move this into the amendment we adopted
on broadband we
intended it to be encompassing of what
we're doing most of this money is coming
in fact i think all of it is coming
from the arpa funds that we're getting
from the federal government
to help our rural towns and counties
have better broadband access which we
found out was
woefully inadequate in many cases as
students tried to do remote learning
so in the house if you're in favor of
adding that language please show
your hands we're unanimous the senate
cain once again that little magical wand
will fix this
yes we'll work with all let's fix this
yes thank you
no it was an amendment we added um
the house is going to take a break and
take a caucus and we're going to be
in room 212. i would anticipate
half an hour mr speaker we're going to
take a break for 30 minutes we will be
back in 30 minutes the time is
2 43 so that will put us a little bit
after three o'clock
mr kane normally
the i believe the house although we call
it magical
lba fixes normally the house and the
senate
uh affirm that lba may make technical
and maintenance changes as
needed so we've done quite a bit of work
and a couple of times including this
recent broadband we've asked you to do
that
so is that is the house in agreement
with that that we're
going to have lba make technical and
maintenance changes
would you like a motion no i think we
can do
consensus to send it in okay so
we know we're coming down to the end of
the wire we know time is getting short
we are going to recess now until 10
o'clock tomorrow morning
and we wanted to be sure you could do
what you needed to do without us around
we are in recess until 10 a.m tomorrow